the jurogan experience there's no part
of the mainstream that looks at
all credible to me anymore well it's
real wacky now
right and here's a here's a wacky one
where the new york times
um is they they're
debunking this idea that the wuhan
lab may have been the source of kovid
when they're like when all these
different people are talking about it
we've been on this for forever
we have been on it forever what it's
extraordinary is the the new york
times is still saying debunked claims
with no evidence whatsoever
you know sauger and jetty from the
rising in the hill had this whole piece
about it on his uh
i love what they're doing they're the
best they're the best well he's got two
channels have you been on
either well i've i've only had him on
here and crystal together but what i
like that was
what you guys did right at the beginning
of that where they explained what
happened i didn't mean to cut you off
what happens in the cycle when your team
wins and your team loses and how
they've both broken out of that and
they've thrown that away yes
that they there that was ten minutes
yeah that i needed to hear that you
i thought you broke new you the three of
you guys broke really new ground
they're what we need there's a
reasonable person on the left and a
reasonable person on the right and
they're both committed to
honesty above all right they might have
different philosophy
together i think crystal is coming
towards sagar because she's seeing
yes the rot on the left yes what my hope
is is that she's going to be
um a credible progressive who's
rejecting all this nonsense
progressivism yeah i think i think
you're right she's very smart and so is
he and the two of them together are
wonderful
what were you going to say before i
catch up what i was going to say is they
were talking about how the new york
times
is is talking about this deep i forget
who they were quoting
who who was uh entertaining this idea
was that what that's right the cdc guy
that he was uh entertaining this idea
this
uh this debunked idea of this
emanating from a lab but it's not
debunked not only is it not debunked
it's more possible than ever but the
problem
is the idea was originally associated
with donald trump
so these [ __ ] at the new york
times still have it in their head
that they can't admit i don't know that
that's what's going on what do you think
it is
well that what they do it's a weird move
we should tell people exactly what what
they're saying
okay the the the former head of the cdc
is saying that it's more probable than
not
he's not saying it's absolute he's
saying it's more probable than not that
it escaped from a lab
right and he details it and he actually
predates it
he goes pre uh you know he goes like
deep into
september and october he believes it
might have
emanated around that time started
spreading they the reason why
is and it all makes total sense this is
an
a very unusual laboratory the laboratory
had been cited in 2018 for safety
protocol violations
the laboratory works on the exact same
kinds of coronaviruses that
cause this worldwide pandemic on bats
they work on bat
yep chronoviruses and this is one of two
level four labs that are in this area so
this this whole
thing is so it's so much more likely
that it emanated from the lab but the
problem is
the the narrative was donald trump is
racist
donald trump calls it the china virus
donald trump says it came from a lab
it can't have come from a lab because
donald trump's always wrong
that's one possibility i'm worried about
something beyond that what are you
worried about
the way that they make this move is that
they synonymize
the lab leak hypothesis with a synthetic
virus
engineered from scratch so in other
words
the idea of like maybe somebody growing
uh
horseshoe bat coronavirus in human lung
tissue
to accelerate natural selection because
like we don't know how to engineer it
but if you let
if you let natural selection engineer it
you can accelerate that right so
instead of saying um we don't know what
to make of
accelerated natural selection in a lab
leaking
they try to make this move which is like
you know there's no sign that this was
engineered
in a lab you're like okay well you
changed what the hypothesis
is in order to say what you're saying to
protect your future
credibility and the thing that i'm
really freaking out about you've been
talking about it brett's been talking
about i've been talking about all sorts
of people have been talking about this
one for a year
i increasingly think that none of these
organizations think that they owe us any
kind of truth
that when they get caught it's just like
yeah of course we had to say that
like what yeah you know like
this time magazine article about of
course we fortified the election
you you what oh yeah we fortified it oh
i did yeah trump was right about a
conspiracy like he
was quoting that who are they quoting
that said they
they fortified the election there was
apparently some entire
group under one guy with hundreds of
activists who
told their people don't riot in the
streets
have a dance party instead i would
highly recommend
time magazine i read the i read the the
blurb about the fortifying
and i was like hmm yeah that's a
disturbing quote but what does it mean
what do what are they trying to mean
with their the claim of the article is
we went right up to the door meddling
with the election
but all we cared about was free and fair
and we had a huge conspiracy so donald
trump wasn't wrong
there was a huge conspiracy but we are
so committed to democracy that even
though we hate donald trump with a
passion that
you know won't let go 24 7 we still
would never do
anything against an election the problem
is with a god like trump
you can almost justify some that's what
i said [ __ ]
if you claim that you're you have to
fight all enemies foreign and domestic
and you claim that he's a russian asset
you're pretty much saying that you have
to do something drastic yeah
and so the number of things that people
claim is what the problem is because
they're not all compatible
and and what i'm trying to get it more
broadly is
over and over i see the same move which
is deny deny deny we get caught yeah
limited hangout yeah we did that [ __ ]
that's the kind of stuff we do because
we have to do it but i don't think
they're saying they got caught
i think they're saying that what we did
was make sure the election was fair it
was
i think the concept of a limited hangout
where you know that
something is too big to hold back so you
push a part of it into the public
not all of it that's the limited and you
let the public think okay well now you
know the truth and it stops there and
then they stop
asking questions because they've got a
new toy to play with catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience